[MUSIC PLAYING]
GEOFFREY NOER: Hello, everybody.
My name is Geoffrey
Noer and I'm here
as a product manager for
Google Cloud Storage.
And I'm here with Michael Yu,
a technical lead with GCS.
MICHAEL YU: Hey, everyone.
GEOFFREY NOER: And we're here
to present the best practices
for storage classes reliability,
performance, and scalability.
And before I get
started, I wanted
to ask for a quick
show of hands.
How many of you in the audience
are actually currently using
Google Cloud Storage?
And then how many people
have not used it yet,
but are interested?
So it's a good mix.
More of you are probably
using it already than not.
I'll go ahead and start
with a relatively quick leap
through the feature set
and the capabilities,
a quick introduction.
And then we'll cut over to
covering some of the key areas.
And Michael will rejoin us
for a demo in a few slides.
So like I said, we'll start
with the introduction.
The three content areas that
are particularly interesting,
we felt, to cover today included
content storage and delivery,
also compute analytics
and machine learning,
and then finally
backup and archive.
All of those are use cases that
we have many, many customers
utilizing GCS today.
So let's start with
that introduction.
So Cloud Storage, it's
actually object storage,
hopefully all of you know.
So we also have block and
file products as part of GCP.
But our Cloud Storage product
is our object storage offering,
which is really the native
cloud format for data.
And what makes, in the end,
the key values of our solution
are that we're trusted,
that we're secure,
we're smart, and simple.
And you'll see all of these
reflected in the capabilities
of the product.
So why have a cloud
storage offering?
It all comes back to
the origins of Google
and the data centers that we've
established around the world
to deliver all of the
products and services
that you're familiar
with outside of GCP,
outside of the Cloud product.
And we had to build extremely
fast, capable networks
across the globe.
We had to create exabytes
of storage capacity
to handle all of the properties
like Gmail and YouTube
and Search.
And so why not have
a cloud offering
that would allow customers
to directly use the Google
infrastructure that has
been built successfully
over all of these years?
So that's one of the
key differentiators
for Cloud Storage.
Even though we're a storage
platform, a storage product,
in the end, it's
the network that
is one of the biggest
advantages of Google Cloud
Platform, its hundreds
of thousands of miles
of fiber optic cable
across the ocean
as well as within continents.
And we have more edge
and peering capabilities
than any other public cloud.
So the three use cases
that I'll be covering today
are content storage
and delivery-- and so
this ranges from everything
from video and music streaming,
website hosting,
multimedia offerings,
mobile app development.
It's any use case
where you have content
and you're bringing it
out to a large user base,
possibly within a continent,
possibly globally.
Compute analytics and
machine learning, of course,
is a very important area that's
receiving a lot of attention
these days.
And here you see a lot of use
in manufacturing, genomics,
e-commerce, internet of
things, all brings customers
to Cloud Storage.
And then finally, I'll cover
the backup and archiving use
case, which is of particular
interest for our Nearline
and Coldline products, so
long-term archives of content
where it's not being accessed
frequently, but when you do
need it, you want
it to be there.
So some of the most
important features--
it's a unified experience.
So I'll be talking about
different ways of storing
your data in Cloud Storage.
But no matter how you store
it, it's the same API,
regardless of storage class.
It's always strongly consistent.
So when you store
data and then you
do a bucket listing of that
data a short time after,
you're guaranteed to see the
data that you just wrote.
And that's not always the case
with cloud storage offerings.
And that simplifies
application development.
We offer a wide array of
geo-redundancy offerings.
So not only just picking--
you can, of course,
just pick one region and
we'll store your data
in that one region.
But if you want to actually
have automatic replication
and have your data served
from multiple regions
to isolate you against
the very rare possibility
of a region-wide outage,
we offer a variety
of ways of making that happen.
And then finally, you saw
the network that I just
showed you for Google.
Well, that allows us,
along with the data
centers that we've put in place,
to have your data be scalable
up to exabytes of content.
So in our case, petabytes of
content is not a scary number.
Hundreds of petabytes,
even, is something
that can be very
easily accomplished.
Exabytes, we may want to
plan a little bit for it.
But we have a lot of
multi-exabyte data center
installations, as well.
So what are the key
terms for object storage?
So first of all,
what's an object?
That's the most base piece.
That's actually,
typically, a file
that you've written as an
object to a particular location.
And this has an object
name associated with it.
Where do you store objects?
Inside buckets.
So buckets are the container.
All of the objects go inside.
You have bucket name.
Where do buckets go?
Well, that's locations.
So a location for Cloud
Storage is you either pick
a region or a
multi-region, which
encompasses multiple regions.
I'll talk about that in a sec.
And that location is where the
bucket is associated with it.
And all of the contents for
that bucket, all of the objects,
end up being stored
within that location.
And then finally we have the
concept of a storage class.
And a storage class is
nothing more, nothing less
than determining the
access frequencies
that you expect your
objects to be served at.
It's the availability
levels and how important
the availability is.
And it also sets
the pricing profile.
So an object that has to
be served a lot and in more
of a hot tier, of course,
is charged for at a higher
level than archive data.
So there are two types of
locations for Cloud Storage.
One is the
multi-regional offering
and the other is
regional in nature.
And your regional
offering, which
is very similar to what is
available with other competing
cloud offerings, you basically
you pick a region anywhere
in the world, and your data
is stored within that region.
Multi-regional is interesting
because we automatically
offer geo-diversity as part
of the storage offering.
So we'll replicate data
across more than one
region within that multi-region.
And a multi-region is
usually a continent.
So we have a US
multi-region, for example,
that constitutes all
of the large data
centers that Google has
within the United States.
Similarly, we have one for
the European Union, called EU.
And we have one
for Asia, as well.
So that allows you to pick
a continent, basically.
Just create a bucket
in that continent.
And we will automatically
store the data in more than one
location within that continent.
And so even if there is a
hurricane or some major event
that takes down a region,
as unlikely as that is,
your data will
still be immediately
available from the
other locations.
And that replication
is done without having
to set up a replication service
or manage it in any way.
It stays a single namespace.
So I've talked about a little
bit of this already, but one
of the key distinctions
between making
that decision between
regional and multi-regional
comes down to trading
off performance
predictability and
high throughput
for co-locating your data.
So if you are, for example,
running analytics workloads
and it's very important that
your GCE installation is
in the same region
as your data, that's
something that you can
accomplish very easily
with regional storage.
With multi-regional,
as you'll see,
while it doesn't allow that
tight co-location of data
and does result in a
little bit higher latency,
it's perfect for content
serving and other areas where
the goal is to host
that data and make it
available across the internet.
So I mentioned storage classes
a couple of slides ago.
And storage classes
basically determine
how the data is stored.
So part of it is whether it's
multi-regional or regional.
Those are basically our
storage classes for hot data.
So it has the highest
service level agreements
associated with them, also,
of course, the higher pricing
to reflect the higher SLAs
and the higher performance.
And then we also have Nearline
and Coldline offerings
that basically allow you
to tier your storage down
to lower-cost
offerings where you
don't expect to be accessing
your data frequently.
So this shows the data
placement at a very, very high
abstracted level.
So don't be distracted
by that some of them
have two boxes and
others have one.
In all cases, the
storage is there
with very high durability.
So we're talking about 11
nines worth of durability.
What's shown here is actually
the availability model
across regions.
So multi-regional storage
class means that the data
exists in more than one region.
With regional and Nearline
and Coldline classes,
they're stored
within one region.
But they're still stored
across availability zones,
allowing large sections
of the data center
or within a metro area to go
offline with the data still
being accessible.
So no matter how you store and
no matter which storage class
it is, the storage
is highly durable.
It's just a question of
that additional question
of the isolation against
potential regional outages.
So that's the
brief introduction.
Now I'm going to go ahead and
start with content storage
and delivery, which
is the first major use
case for Cloud Storage.
So there are actually
four common setups
that we see with
content serving,
and the simplest to
understand is direct serving.
Basically, you put your
content in the Cloud.
And you serve it
directly from the Cloud.
You pay egress rates based on
where the data is being read.
And you take advantage
automatically
of all of the edge caching
and points of presence
that Google has everywhere.
However, we also have
a Cloud CDN offering.
And what this does is it
allows you to actually save
on the cost
associated with egress
if the data is already cached.
It also allows you
to take advantage
of some additional
security offerings.
I'll get into some more
details there in a moment.
There's also the ability
to do custom front ends
if you want to have additional
intelligence and more
dynamic content.
And then finally,
you can also use
Google Cloud Storage
in conjunction
with independent CDNs.
So these are all possibilities.
Let me go into some more details
on the next couple of slides.
So direct serving, what
would the best practices
be for direct serving?
So one of them is to use
the multi-regional class.
This ensures that you
have high availability
for all of your data
with that geo-redundancy.
And you can also set
cache control headers
to enable edge caching.
So let's go ahead and
take a look at a demo just
to see how you still
get some advantages
from our local caching.
MICHAEL YU: Here we
have a sample bucket
that I've created.
It's called io107-demo.
And what I want to show
you is that this bucket was
created in the Europe location.
It's a multi-regional bucket,
so it's pretty far away from us.
And I've created an object
in here called google.png.
And we can go ahead
and open that up.
And it's the Google logo,
so nothing too special
here so far.
I'm going go ahead and open
up the developer tools here.
And this will give us a little
bit of timing information
for loading this PNG.
And you can see that
when I reloaded it,
it took about 366 milliseconds.
And that makes sense
because this asset is
hosted all the way in Europe.
So first of all, one
thing I wanted to show
is that even though this
object is in Europe,
it's actually using
Google's global network.
And it's connecting right away.
And most of the
request is actually
transited on Google's network.
And one way we can
take a look at that
is by running a trace
route to the domain here,
storage.googleapis.com.
So let me go ahead and do that.
And so this is tracing
the path to the server.
And you can see here at the
very end, one of the things
is the latency.
It's about five or
six milliseconds.
So this is clearly somewhere
closer than Europe.
And we can actually take
a little bit closer look
to see where that is.
So if you look at
the server name,
it's actually a little
bit interesting.
It says NUQ and then
a few other things.
It also says 1e100.net.
So what does this all mean?
Well, first of all,
1e100.net, if you search
for the definition of googol,
which is actually what
our company should have been
named, but we misspelled it,
it's 1e100.
So this is kind of like a code
name for a device that we own.
And what about NUQ?
NUQ ends up being
Moffett Federal Air
Field, which is an airfield
pretty close by here
in San Jose.
The devices aren't actually
located in the airfield.
But it gives you
a hint that we're
ending up terminating the
connection somewhere in the Bay
Area.
And once we terminate
that connection,
we then go ahead and transit the
request across our own network
all the way to Europe.
OK, the request is mostly
transiting over our network.
But it is taking a long time.
So in order to
enable edge caching,
its just a simple matter of
changing the cache control
headers.
So here I want to change
the catch control headers
from no cache to public.
And now if I go ahead
and reload a few times,
you can see that it's
gone down from about 300,
400 milliseconds down to
about 15 milliseconds.
And that's because
this asset is now
being served directly
from the edge cache
here in the Bay Area.
So--
GEOFFREY NOER: OK, thank you.
Very good.
And now let's change
back to the content.
Great.
So now we've seen the
edge cache in action.
So I think that
hopefully gives you
a little bit of a clue as to
why content delivery is such
a good fit for Cloud Storage.
And so what about Cloud CDN?
You automatically
get some advantage
from that, that you
just saw with the demo.
But Cloud CDN is an
additional offering
that allows you to
control the custom domain.
So if you want
HTTPS, if you want
to take advantage of some
differentiated pricing
by not being charged
egress, lower egress
pricing when you're correctly
hitting the edge caches,
and it also allows you to handle
static and dynamic request
handling from the same domain.
So some valuable
additional features.
You can also do
custom front ends.
And this can be done with
or without Cloud CDN.
But basically this
allows you to also
have a GCE instance doing
some custom dynamic transforms
of data, authorizations, that
sort of thing, in the path.
And then the data is served.
And again, it can be cached.
So we see a lot of either direct
serving or the use of Cloud CDN
and/or custom front ends.
It all depends on the nature
of the content delivery
requirements.
So the final aspect here
is using independent CDNs.
So yes, Google provides a
lot of offerings that allow
you to do it all from Google.
But there are actually a lot of
valid and very useful reasons
why you might want
to consider using
an independent CDN as part
of the picture, as well.
So we have partnerships with
Akamai, Cloudflare, Fastly,
Highwinds, Level 3, Limelight,
Verizon, and others.
And all of them offer specific
features, reach, or redundancy
for their particular network.
They may be specialized
for a particular industry.
They may have
offerings and features
that you want to take advantage
of that we don't have yet.
And really, the
thing that you need
to consider when you're
using an independent CDN
is basically the concept
of an origin shield
and where that's
located geographically.
So typically with
an independent CDN,
instead of using a
multi-regional storage class,
you should actually use
a regional storage class.
And the reason for
that is you can
co-locate it close to
where the origin shield is
for the independent CDN.
That origin shield is
basically the block
between ensuring that not
too much egress happens
from Google.
So it helps control your
costs and keep the caching
within your independent CDN.
OK, so with that, that's
a brief introduction
into the content
delivery direction
with the Cloud Storage.
And now I'd like to
bring Michael back up.
And he will talk a little
bit about compute analytics
and machine learning.
MICHAEL YU: Thank you, Geoff.
OK.
So I'm going to
cover essentially
data processing use cases.
And there's quite a
lot of variety here.
So quite a lot of variety,
quite a lot of specialized tools
and frameworks and
services you can use.
So we're not going to have
enough time to go into those.
So we'll, instead, cover a
few generic best practices
and rules of thumb that
should apply to most of them.
So let's first take a
look at how GCS or Cloud
Storage is used within these
data processing pipelines.
And the first case
is source data.
This is the primary
input into your pipeline.
Cloud Storage is pretty
popular because there's
a variety of
different data formats
and object storage
doesn't really
care what your format is.
For most pipelines,
you end up reading
the majority of your data.
So you really care about
aggregate throughput.
So the key thing here
is to use regional
and to co-locate your
storage with your compute.
That's going to give you the
highest aggregate throughput.
It's going to keep
all of the transfer
within the in-region network.
The second type is
intermediate data.
This is data that's produced
by one stage of your pipeline
and then consumed by another
stage of your pipeline.
And here it's a
little bit trickier.
If you care about
data persistence,
for example, if your pipeline
is doing something expensive
and you want to be able to
resume the computation midway
through if something goes wrong,
then GCS makes sense to use.
And in that case, the
recommendation is the same.
Go ahead and use
regional and co-locate
your storage with your data.
However, in some cases,
it actually makes
sense to not use GCS
and to use something
a little bit more
transient, where
you don't care about persisting
this intermediate data
and you can get a little
bit higher throughput.
So for example, in
some Hadoop cases,
you can use HDFS and run HDFS
on top of a persistent disk
or local SSD.
And that will enable you
to scale even higher.
We also have things like
Cloud Dataflow, which
offer more specialized
services like a shuffle service
for specific operations.
And so when you can use
those, those sometimes
make sense rather
than running your own
and using GCS as
intermediate data.
Third type is side
inputs and staging data.
So unlike primary
inputs, primary inputs
you typically divide
your input into shards
and you distribute them
to various compute nodes.
Side inputs are inputs
that you distribute
to all of your compute nodes.
So this might be, for
example, a mapping table
which each compute node can then
transform your primary inputs
with.
Similarly, staging
data is any data
that you would stage on each of
your compute nodes beforehand.
So here you can go
ahead and use two GCS.
You can use regional.
But it's actually OK
to use multi-regional,
as well, if you want
higher availability.
And the reason why is
that because you're
doing repeated reads,
GCS will automatically
cache your data locally.
And so those
repeated fetches will
come from within the region.
And you're not going to
be constrained in terms
of aggregate throughput.
And then finally,
final outputs--
this one's a little
bit trickier.
The storage class
recommendation really
depends on what you're going
to do with those outputs.
So if you're going to use these
outputs to do content serving,
you might use the
recommendations that Geoff just
gave for content serving.
If you're going to use them
to feed into another pipeline,
than you might use
the recommendations
we gave earlier for source data.
So it really depends
on your use case
to determine what kind of
storage class you want to use.
So next, one common
question we get
is how large should
my objects be?
I have a large object, should
I fetch that in chunks?
If I want to upload an object,
should I upload that in chunks?
And to understand the
recommendation here,
we actually need to take
a look at the performance
profile of Cloud Storage.
These are very, very
rough rules of thumb.
I've rounded them up to make
them a little bit easier
to remember.
They're powers of
two as well, roughly.
And here we see that we have
about a 100 millisecond time
to first byte on reads.
We have about a 200 millisecond
fix latency cost for writes.
Now, as the object
sizes get larger,
you're able to achieve about
800 megabits per second on read
and 400 megabits per
second on writes.
So the key thing I
want to call here
is that there is a
relatively high fixed latency
cost per request.
And so that means
if you're going
to be doing a lot
of small requests
and you're doing
them serially, you're
paying that latency every time.
And your aggregate throughput
is not going to be great.
And that's what this graph on
the right hand side is showing.
The smaller the
request size, the lower
the aggregate
throughput you're going
to get when you're issuing
these requests sequentially.
So the general best practice is
to favor larger request sizes
and object sizes
whenever you can.
We recommend typically
two megabytes or larger,
if possible.
If you do need to do a
smaller request size,
go ahead and parallelize
those small requests.
So for example, one of
the common things we see
are people move an existing
pipeline over to the Cloud.
And they might have
something like they
might list files and then
perform some operation
on each file one by one.
If you, instead,
parallelize those,
you're going to be able to get
a lot better overall throughput.
So next I want to
talk a little bit
about autoscaling for Cloud
Storage and some of the best
practices there.
And to understand
that, we have to look
at how Cloud Storage ends
up sharding or splitting up
your data.
So Cloud Storage uses something
called range-based sharding.
What that means is
it takes your data
and it splits into
lexicographical ranges.
And so in this
particular example,
we have three ranges, A
through G, G through S, and S
through the end of the alphabet.
And any object whose name
falls within the range
will get assigned to that
corresponding shared.
So for example, if I have an
object that starts with B,
it will fall into that
first shard, A through G.
And the reason why we do this
type of sharding strategy
is to provide
consistent listing.
So imagine I want to
list all the objects that
start with T. This is actually
pretty easy to service.
It simply needs to
query a single shard.
And that shard has all
of the information needed
to respond to that query.
So in contrast, if you look
at the hash-based sharding
approach, this approach you
essentially, for example,
you would hash the
name of the object.
You might mod it
by four and then
assign objects to shards
based off of that mod.
And if we were to service that
same list objects request,
the problem is we
now no longer know
which shards contain
objects that start with T.
So we have to query
every single shard.
And what happens
if a shard is slow,
like that yellow arrow, or
a shard returns an error,
like the red arrow?
In that case, we
have a tough choice.
We can either wait or ignore
the error, in which case
we're returning an inconsistent
or incomplete listing--
sorry.
We could either ignore
the error, in which case
we would be returning
a incomplete listing,
or we could retry or serve
the error, in which case
we'd be providing a
higher error rate overall.
And you can tell, as the
number of shards increases,
this becomes a bigger
and bigger problem.
So this is why we use
range-based sharding.
So GCS, like I mentioned,
it automatically scales.
So it will detect when a
particular range is getting
hot, in this case, G through S.
And it will go ahead and split
that into two smaller ranges to
try to split the load evenly.
And so this happens
automatically.
And most of the time, you
don't have to worry about it.
Generally speaking, you can get
about 1,000 writes per second
and about 5,000 reads
per second without having
to worry about anything at all.
Beyond that, it often takes
up to about 20 minutes for GCS
to figure out that a
shard needs to be split.
And it will go ahead
and split that.
So for many use
cases, you really
don't have to worry about this.
However, if you are scaling up
beyond some of these numbers,
then one of the best
practices is really
to make sure you're
distributing your load evenly.
This really helps out our
auto-splitting algorithm
to scale load evenly.
So I'm going to talk about this
in a little bit more detail.
And one of the most common ways
that load is not distributed
evenly is sequential access.
So I'm going to go through
a little bit of detail
to kind of give you
a flavor for why this
is so challenging to deal with.
So I imagine we have
sequential access where
we're accessing objects g, h,
i, j, k, et cetera, all the way
through q.
And imagine we had
split our shards like I
showed in the previous slide.
So we have a shard
of G through N,
and another shard, N
through R. The problem here
is that when you do sequential
access, the first set
of accesses all hit one
shard, the G through N shard.
And then once you get to the
second half of the accesses,
they all hit the second
shard, the N through R shard.
And so at any given
point in time,
you're still lasering or
hot spotting a single shard.
And splitting those
shards hasn't really
distributed that load across
the two shards evenly.
So this hasn't really
helped us scale.
You might ask, well, how
can we get around this?
And one of the ways
you can get around this
is to further split
into more shards.
So here's an example
where we split it
into very fine-grained shards.
Each shard is only taking
a single letter at a time.
And so this definitely works
in terms of scaling load.
But the problem is that
there's fragmentation.
And fragmentation,
again, basically
boils down to how do you
provide consistent listing?
So again, when we only had
two shards, issuing a listing
request only needed to talk
to, say, one shard at a time,
versus now, with
many, many shards,
the same listing
request is going
to have to split up and
talk to multiple shards
at the same time.
And we run into
the same problems
where any one shard can be
slow or can return an error.
And that will cause
a listing problem.
So this is essentially
a fundamental trade-off
between strong listing
consistency and hot-spotting.
So here are a couple of ways
you can work around this.
If you're doing bulk operations
and they're doing them
sequentially, you can try
to do them in parallel
under different prefixes.
And this will cause, in
this particular case,
foo and bar are
different prefixes.
GCS will notice that there
is consistent load to each
of those prefixes.
It will split.
And you'll be able to
double your total throughput
rate that you can achieve.
Similarly, if you don't
care about listing order,
you can hash the object name
and insert that hash somewhere
into the object name prefix.
And this will cause your load
to essentially randomly hit,
essentially, what looks like
random object names, which
will provide a nice, even load.
So again, the drawback
there, though,
is that your listing order
is going to be different.
OK.
Next I'm going to talk
about timeouts and retries.
And it sounds dry, but it's
really important for data
processing workloads
because you are typically
spiking up in your traffic.
And you're more likely to hit
some temporary bottlenecks.
And so generally when people
think timeouts and retries,
use exponential backoff and
jitter and we're done, right?
This is a little bit more
complicated than that.
So aside from using
exponential backoff and jitter,
the first recommendation
we have is
to use idle timeouts instead
of absolute timeouts.
And the reason why is imagine
the system temporarily
has constrained bandwidth.
And you set an absolute
timeout of two seconds,
but your request
needs, I don't know,
let's say two and 1/2
seconds to complete.
What you'll end
up doing is you'll
end up waiting for two
seconds, canceling the request,
retrying it, waiting two seconds
again, canceling the request,
and you never end
up making progress.
So if you, instead,
were tracking,
when was the last
time I made progress,
and after two seconds
of no progress
canceling your request, then you
end up handling this case much
more gracefully.
You'll go ahead and
allow entire request
to take two and 1/2 seconds.
And you're going to be able
to achieve positive goodput,
even though throughput-- or,
sorry, available bandwidth-- is
decreasing.
The second recommendation,
aside from exponential backoff
and jitter, is to use new
connections for retries.
So the reason you
wanted to do this
is that if you get an
error, it's oftentimes
because you happened to hit
one of the machines that
aren't in our large fleet.
And that machine
might be acting up.
Again, we have
many, many machines.
And so it's possible
that any given machine is
unhealthy for a period of time.
So by establishing
a new connection
you're increasing the
likelihood that you connect
to a new front end machine.
And you're not reissuing
the same requests
to an unhealthy
front end machine.
The third recommendation
is to make
sure to use
idempotent sequences.
So whenever you are issuing
retries, if it mutates state,
you're at risk of having
unintended consequences.
And the common pattern
we end up seeing here
is folks who issue a delete.
So imagine you issue a delete
request and that request
is taking a long time.
So you stop waiting.
You issue it again.
And the second request
succeeds quickly
because you've used the
previous recommendations.
It had hit a new machine.
And now you've gone ahead and
you've deleted your object.
Now imagine you write a
new version of that object.
And so you've got a
newly created version.
And that succeeds as well.
And finally, what happens
if that very first request
that was taking a long time
actually ends up succeeding?
Well, that very first
request is going
to delete the
newly-created object.
And all of a sudden,
you have data loss.
So this is pretty severe if
you're not careful about it.
So when we say use
idempotent sequences,
there's a couple of
ways you can do this.
One way is to simply
make sure you only write
and never overwrite an object.
And that's pretty
draconian in terms
of what you're able to do.
Another approach
is to use something
we call preconditions,
which allows
you to add a precondition--
it allows you to add
a condition to a request that
causes the request to abort
if that condition isn't met.
So in that previous
example, I could have said,
please delete object A only
if it's generation number one.
And if I did that, then when I
created the object A later on,
it would have a
different generation,
generation number two.
And now that slow delete
request would no longer
apply to that generation
and it would be harmless.
The fourth recommendation
is to limit retry volume.
And a rough rule of thumb is to
limit your retries to, perhaps,
10% of your total traffic.
The rationale here is that if
the service is truly unhealthy,
then additional retries
beyond this won't really help.
And so retries are typically
for the transient sort
of low error percentage cases.
This helps out the
service, clearly,
because you're not slamming it.
But it also helps your client.
One of the common
things we see is clients
will retry indefinitely.
And they'll end up building
a queue within themselves.
And it causes the
client to fall over.
So this ends up helping
with flow control a bit
if you limit your retries.
And finally, the last
recommendation we have,
it's a little bit of
an advanced technique,
so you really
should only use this
if you really need to
control your tail latency.
But it's to go ahead
and use hedged requests.
And a hedged request is
essentially a request
that you issue if your initial
request doesn't come back
in time.
So for example, you might
use your P95 latency--
I gave a rough rule of
thumb, about 100 milliseconds
for reads--
and you might wait
100 milliseconds
for that initial
request to come back.
If it doesn't, you can
issue a second request.
And in most cases,
if you got unlucky
and that first request
happened to hit
just one of the rare
unhealthy machines,
the second request is going
to complete very quickly,
typically under 100
milliseconds 95% of the time.
So this means your
99.75% latency
will be under 200 milliseconds
with this technique.
In the rare case where
the system is overloaded,
the initial request
is still ongoing.
And so you can go ahead and wait
for that to complete, as well.
And so this doesn't really
have too many drawbacks,
as long as you are limiting
the total number of retries
that you are issuing.
So this is, again, an
advanced technique.
If you're interested
in it, there
was a great paper called
"The Tail at Scale",
written by Jeff Dean.
And you can look that up.
And it goes into little bit
more detail on how to do this.
Finally, I wanted to talk a
little bit about the Hadoop use
case because I
know a lot of folks
have Hadoop workloads on-prem
and they're thinking about how
to move it to the cloud.
And I wanted to mention that we
have a service called Dataproc.
It's a managed Hadoop service.
It allows you to
bring up new clusters.
It implements a lot
of the best practices
that we've talked about.
In particular, it configures
HDFS with local SSD by default.
So you can use that
for temporary data
or intermediate data.
It also installs a Hadoop
file system connector for GCS
by default, as well.
So what this allows you to do
is it allows your Hadoop jobs
to access source data directly
from GCS without first copying
it into your HDFS cluster.
A lot of the best
practices we've already
talked about-- using local SSD,
paralyzing small operations.
The other thing I
wanted to mention,
the biggest difference
I think folks
find when they move from
on-prem Hadoop to the cloud,
is that Cloud Storage
is a object storage, not
a file system.
So it doesn't have a
true directory semantics.
For example, it doesn't support
atomic directory rename.
So this will
oftentimes require you
to tweak your job a little bit.
For example, one common
pattern we've seen
is folks will write files
into a temporary directory
and then when that temporary
directory is complete,
they'll atomically
rename that directory
into a final location.
And that signals a later part
of their pipeline to say,
hey, all my data is here.
So because Cloud Storage doesn't
support that atomic directory
operation, an
alternative method is
to write your objects into
the final destination.
And when all of your
objects are complete,
you can write a success file.
And the presence of
that success file
says, hey, the next stage of
the pipeline is ready to go.
So there are some
tricks with this
that you might need to do
to update your pipeline
to get it to work around the
lack of directory atomicity.
OK, with that, I'm going to
hand it back over to Geoff
to talk about
backup and archive.
GEOFFREY NOER: Great.
So backup and archive
is the last area
that we'll talk about today.
And a little bit
shorter because this
is a relatively simple
but important area.
And we have two different
cool storage classes.
So we talk about the different
hotness and coolness of data.
And the main multi-regional
class and regional classes,
those are our hot tier.
But if you want to tier down
to less frequently-accessed
storage, this is where Nearline
and Coldline come into play.
And here, the difference,
all of the storage classes
are instant access speeds.
So you're never waiting for
data to come off of tape.
The latencies are very
similar across all
of the storage classes.
You're always using
the same APIs.
So that's also consistent.
And you always benefit
from strong consistency.
So actually, there's
more commonality
across the different
storage classes
than there are differences.
But those differences
come down to what
is the ideal access frequency.
And for Nearline, you'll
find that, of course,
you can access more
frequently than this.
But if you limit it to no
more than once per month,
then your pricing will end up
being really advantageous to be
in the Nearline storage class.
And similarly, if you expect
to access less often than once
per year for truly
cold-archived data,
then you'll benefit strongly
from using a Coldline class.
So the way that this is priced
is basically the hot tiers,
you pay more per gigabyte month.
But on the flip side, there's
actually no retrieval charge
in the hot classes.
For Nearline and
Coldline, you start
to pay more for retrieval as
your storage class goes down.
But the performance
behavior is very consistent.
So the use cases for
Nearline and Coldline,
because of that frequency
of access difference,
you tend to see backups
actually being more associated
with Nearline than Coldline.
Anything around
content serving where
it's a long-tail archive that's
just infrequently accessed
but it needs to be available
and ready to share,
that would be usually more
of a Nearline access pattern.
And then some
analytics workloads
where the data is very
infrequently accessed,
you're better off with Nearline.
Coldline is really much more
about the long-term archives--
so tape replacements, disaster
recovery implementations,
multimedia source
file storage where
you need to have it around but
you're really not accessing it
very frequently, those are
all cases to use Coldline.
Now, these storage classes
don't exist just on their own.
It's really part of a larger
storage tiering capability
that we offer.
So you can set up an
automated lifecycle
which will move data
automatically based
on the age of the objects.
So this is just one
particular illustration
here where you've
chosen, in this example,
to say, after 30 days,
move from the hot tiers
of either multi-regional
or regional
and move those to Nearline.
And then after 90 days
of additional storage
there, move it to Coldline,
and then after a year,
delete the data.
So maybe that's what
your profile looks like.
If it's not, you
could tweak this
to however you want it to be.
But what's nice
is you can really
set it up so that the objects
are migrated automatically
down to lower cost storage as
the age of the data increases.
So I mean, number one thing
to say about backup is, just
because it's cloud doesn't
make it automagically
protected against every
single possible incidence
and occurrence that might occur.
Just like in an on-prem, there
are still backup considerations
that you need to take
into account for Cloud.
So don't overlook having a
backup strategy, number one.
We provide a lot
of features that
aid you in preventing
accidental deletion.
So a few of those that
are the most important
include object versioning,
the lifecycle capabilities,
and being able to lock down
delete support for backups.
So all of those help isolate
you against accidental deletion
of data.
And especially for the
backups of on-prem data,
so cloud backup capabilities,
the general rules
of understanding what
your backup windows are
and what your restore
times look like are
equally applicable to Cloud as
they are for on-prem backup.
It's the latencies and the
size of the network pipes
that are in place
between your data center
and Cloud that count.
So understanding
what your throughput
is, how fast can you
do those backups,
how fast can you
restore, that helps you.
As long as you can set that up
to meet your business needs,
you'll be set with Cloud Backup.
And we do see different
deployment patterns for backup.
We have the Cloud backup.
We also have Cloud
gateway type setups
where there's maybe a
dedupe engine in the middle.
There are a lot of different
ways to set this up.
I won't spend too
much time on this
except to really emphasize
that one area that we've really
emphasized with our partners
is the native integrations
of Cloud Storage with
our backup partners.
So these are native
integrations taking advantage
of all the features of both
our backup partners and Cloud
Storage.
And they include partnerships
with Commvault, Veritas,
Cohesity, Actifio, Rubrik,
Dell EMC, Unitrends, CloudBerry
Labs, others.
So this is a very comprehensive
portfolio of partners.
And we encourage
you to check out
those integrations
for your backup needs
because it really simplifies
taking advantages of those best
practices and just making
it happen smoothly.
So with that, I'd like to thank
you all for attending today.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]